fans that have been patiently waiting
for updates on the next Splinter Cell
got their first taste of what Sam
Fisher's next mission is going to look
like Ubisoft taking the original game
and rebuilding it from the ground up in
its own Snowdrop engine unveiled concept
art of the Remake in celebration of the
franchise's 20th anniversary during a
conversation as a part of that
celebration with the development team at
ubsoft Toronto Associates level design
director zavian Porter explained the
goal of the project is to create a quote
Top tier remake to push quality as much
as possible that should help us set a
good foundation for the franchise going
forward so it sounds like the Remake
itself won't be a simple one-off it also
sounds like the Remake will incorporate
mechanics and elements from other games
in the franchise that followed the
original's release with senior game
designer Andy Schmall stating that the
team is quote explore covering new and
Innovative Tech and ideas as well as
features and elements from the other
Splinter Cell titles unfortunately this
will be the last update for the much
anticipated remake for a while as the
tune will be quote going dark for a
little while so it can focus on making
the absolute best possible game in the
meantime fans both new and old can
experience the original game which was
initially an exclusive for the very
first Xbox for the great deal of free
the deal can be obtained via Ubisoft
itself for the PC speaking of Xbox
Ubisoft and Deals Black Friday discounts
for the two gaming Giants are already
out in the wild Xbox is discounting its
Series S console to 250 highlights of
its game sales include Madden NFL 23 for
35 Tiny Tina's Wonderland's Next Level
Edition also for 35 and to The Witcher 3
wild Hunt Game of the Year Edition for
10 which will be getting a free next-gen
upgrade in December from Ubisoft 20 20s
Assassin's Creed Valhalla last year's
Far Cry 6 and this year's Rainbow Six
extraction can all be nabbed for under
20 for both Xbox and ubisoft's full list
of deals as well as our complete
collection of Black Friday discounts
head to gamespot.com if you do pick up a
shiny new Xbox series s on sale you're
going to want to apply the latest
software update which brings some much
welcome additions and tweaks to the
platform the biggest of which being
tighter integration with Discord Discord
integration launched for Xbox insiders
back in July and for all console users
in September but previously you had to
transfer the call from Discord to your
console via the Xbox mobile app now you
can activate Discord voice calls
directly from the console itself other
new updates include notifications when
games on your Xbox store wishlist go on
sale as well as better and deeper
Integrations for live streaming and
capturing footage of full list of
updates in the link in the description
are you looking forward to the Splinter
Cell remake what Black Friday gaming
deals are you gonna take advantage of
let us know in the comments and we'll
see you next time for more Gamespot news
[Music]